Oh
Ron example the in the mirror at Bayern
Munich's training center with claudio
pizarro he's got showered put on cologne
and dressed up to spend some time with
us and let us do this interview thank
you for that would take a flower on my
leg my pleasure how many people here
speak Spanish do you hear more Spanish
than German ponyal a 0 le pas le mas
penetrante kelali man tratamos of course
we try to speak German cuz we train
together with lots of Germans but I've
just played with a group of Latino
players so we spoke mostly Spanish shabi
bonatti oh he speaks Italian Rafa can
speak Spanish and Pepe Reina the Baldwin
there were just the four of us and one
German in the group is it an urban myth
that you sometimes help Guardiola with
translation or is that true joy to see
what no he could already speak some
German when he got here he asks about
words now and then but no more he
learned very quickly which words for
example what are the worst it I can't
remember in conversation you'll
sometimes ask how do you say this then I
try to help yeah exactly does he'll
throw their pickup
bambara Vita little sad the bomber from
the Andes do you remember when you got
this nickname for keyboard I really
don't because it's made up by a
journalist I don't know where it came
from but once someone said it it's stuck
it seems like a nice nickname say the
bomber from the Andes in German américa
latina in a lemon cut out no boom boom
bye dear from the London order and I'll
see no suena know soon away no me haces
en Boombah Boombah so st. Marcoux mobile
yo the top non-german goalscorer in the
Bundesliga that is a South American
americano por ESO nosotros esta mejor es
de frio bueno gente sabe pero esta como
se siente cuando una cuchara so it
really is something very special it
makes me feel very proud to be the
record foreign goal scorer in a
competitive league that has lots of
tradition without a doubt it's something
very special for me to wait to see what
I mean but oh this is de como do you
feel like you've become a piece of
Bundesliga history see of course
everyone here says that it's something
very special who says that everyone and
latin american and spanish players
always call me the historic striker in
particular rafinha likes to make jokes
like that but it is really special y
creo es algo muy respite alley what more
can you do when you're already the top
foreign goalscorer in the Bundesliga
meet elemental OC I want to become one
of the top all-time five goals scores in
the Bundesliga obviously catching dirt
Miller the top man on the list is
impossible he scored too many goals but
to be among the top five is possible I'm
an eighth place right now and if i'm not
mistaken i'm only one or two goals
behind sixth place yeah quien SE mas o
menos o Dolci it's difficult but not
impossible como en la cosa pero es
posible escuchame now we're gonna get
some Peruvian food do you want some you
must be hungry after training Anakin is
a little odd
horse he does your wife Carla cook
Peruvian food see sometimes but not
often usually we'd like to go out to
restaurants for lunch whenever we can we
go to Nazca a peruvian place well I must
what's up with all the luck do you feel
at home when you walk through Munich
when everyone at training is shouting
Pizarro Pizarro row seat well the people
here are very respectful sometimes they
want an autograph or a photo but they
treat you nicely and with respect big
kissing me what does that mean become
shall we leave the philosophical stuff
for later in the restaurant and took up
a deck work without with them perfect
what do ver de bremen mean to you hey I
feel a lot of affection for the club it
opened the door to European football for
me when I came here I went to their to
Bremen an interesting club when you're
talking about Germany a club that had
just won the cup that was not easy ck
you got one too ok but I me it out so I
came to a club that had just made it
into European competition I read them
very highly I love them I have lots of
friends and brave it's a very special
city for me and what about buying Munich
hey it's from that party let's take a
breath it's another number to a media me
irons a huge part of my life about all I
know in terms of my career for Cuba
committee hola Maya I won most of my
titles here a party so but also in terms
of my family meowmy sequel the amethyst
the youngest of my three children was
born here in Munich and the other two
were born in Bremen I mean they're all
at home here you movie which was another
guy us tom bro so we'll stay in this
city we already decided I'm us you
you've almost OEM you know such clever
your deck or do you remember the day
when the people from Werder Bremen saw
you in Peru for the first time do you
ever think about that
pero entiendo de primera vez de pensar
sabia SI was whistle of course I always
try to keep everything that's happened
in my life in perspective I always take
time to analyze the year I've had
everything that I've done well or not so
well model mb it's the but I always try
to find things I can improve on and to
do things in future better okay be
anything I'm will be in the time when I
left Peru was special to me since I
arrived here everything's gone well
Vicki aqui la cosa me fueron muy bien
and my career's gone well too pero ESO
quiero avanzando llamo Sam me carrera
pero sin alemannia aachen you came here
in 1999 went first to Bremen and then to
chelsea in London they know it you've
spent a lot of time in Europe later on
here at Bayern Munich but that first
phase was it difficult for you you see
father I'm him but I Flavio be sorrow si
si yes new cultures are always
complicated above all seeing new things
in a country that I didn't know at all
gonna head to start it wasn't easy to
adapt to a new culture and I'd been told
the Germans are a little complicated and
cold sorry man is how I see Romeo
complicado free really what Antony
bragging oh absolutely I tried not to
make any judgments until I got to know
him but many people told me that ok
mucho mucha gente camels were you on a
medium did you come on your own or with
Connor was parallel see so she's been
with you for your whole career right we
were already married I adapted to the
culture here it wasn't easy but I got
used to it always the nickel to me
where's Lizzie it what extent can a
player decide his own future
you can decide everything if things go
well porque al finales de cuando la cosa
van saliendo en la final say you the
manager or the club it's always me you
went away from Bremen because you didn't
want to carry on there and then you did
the same with vinyl is that right yes we
didn't see if they don't if we little
bit yes I left Bremen because there was
something new and better waiting for me
it wasn't hard for Bremen to understand
that completely understood my situation
as a young player who was forging a
career and they knew that at any moment
the bigger club might come along and
want to buy name siempre Metatron muy
bien creo que te wees treated me well
and I think that went both ways that's
why I still have such good memories of
that club when the time comes for you to
make a decision do you all sit together
at home and decide together that it's
time for something new if you want to go
to the Premier League or Dubai or back
to South America or that you want to
stay at Bayern Munich why do you discuss
that with Connor in your children I'd
like to follow your wallet chicos Y Roco
to visit irides increasing cream is
incredible that you're asking that goes
just yesterday the family was sitting
together and my children started asking
what are we going to do now my son said
we're going to have a family meeting and
decide together right yeah they would we
had first time that I've done something
like that before my children were still
too young for it wow what a mechanic
easy you played now my oldest son is 15
and he can express his opinion and say
he wants to go here or there they stayed
Billy and Carla and I will decide it's
important to listen to them and know
what they think get okay you're getting
to an important age or they have to make
decisions about University which school
you go to yeah the course which courses
the technical these things influence the
decisions that I have to make the
meeting is the moment they said does
your son tell you for instance papa you
didn't play well today yes Dean not so
much this year cuz I haven't played much
he asked me why I didn't play he just
doesn't understand that very well and
what did you answer well because the
coach didn't pick me simple as that yes
I see this day now my son's understand
that pretty well because I explained it
to him what my youngest is the one who
likes soccer the most so he's the most
upset when I don't play he's the
happiest when I run out onto the pitch
he understands the situation completely
and I think that's great getting back to
guardiola I've never interviewed anyone
who has had both him and Mourinho as a
coach I'm Maureen your little games look
I think they're only 40 so only a few
very few it out and so ladies and
gentlemen I am a sitting in a car with a
player who was trained by Mourinho and
now is trained by Guardiola where the
order I asked your former Chelsea
team-mate franco de Santo if he'd rather
play for guardiola or Mourinho he
answered Mourinho and you hey you're not
the way I want no comment to my 50
political I walk one over the other pero
in de lo digo porque porque I'm
diplomatic but i will tell you know i'll
make it easy for you what's Guardiola
got an wats Mourinho como yo lo tiene es
una strata gar impressionen Guardiola is
a formidable strategist Ebola money hot
he's an Astra tactician yeah we'll try
to be about it he studies the opposing
team very closely equipo para llevar y
manifesto muy bien y and he deploys the
right players against the opponent's
moni he's a great strategist look at
Mourinho communicated well with his
players yo creo que no way who else that
you got along with him quite well what
is right I played with him for three
months muy poco believe but I've read
articles let's think of a great mutual
affection no no see see that I see broke
okay Chrissy with you well yes on my
part as I've often said before it met a
great deal to me that he called me
personally to say he wanted me on his
team you with dental keepo it does it
but you need to him it is unique it's
above and beyond a no
the way he relates to his players that's
how he gets the players to give their
all for him on the pitch they do put a
little company we've seen quite often
the way his players always stand behind
him they always support him they're
inseparable he gets the players to give
them all they've got SI pero es algo SI
really do give him all a con hace que
los que los borre siempre dent oprah
know how do you feel in Munich how
Bavarian can a Peruvian be borrow is
poisonous lmp2 100 fine I'm happy to be
here siento muy muy muy contento de
estar a que lo hecho muchas veces st
cuantas family dental dresses do you
have at home cuanto en tu casa barrio
well we've got a few because my wife and
I like to go to oktoberfest it's so
great there it's a very special festival
here in Bavaria and she wears her dirndl
is quite often tell me as if lederhosen
do you have oh my gosh you know yeah I
how much Bavarian beer can a Peruvian
body take quite a lot in Peru we drink a
lot of beer and that's typical of here
too yeah Carl oktoberfest as often as we
can to party and enjoy ourselves yeah he
flew todo lo que si stay locked office
you
is the restaurant we're going to now the
same one claudio pizarro takes his
family to on Sundays secret yes in fact
we always come here on Sunday it opens
up one o'clock on sunday but at five on
other days yellow mean with it opens at
midday on sunday so we can come here for
lunch listen what is wrong and what do
you eat for lunch on sunday in peru in
Argentina we have barbecues we can ask
our cameraman from Mexico what they
there on Sundays what about Peru here we
always try to eat Peruvian cuisine
ceviche for instance or pan-fried
sirloin or peruvian chicken fricassee
what statistic do you like best the one
for top goal scorer Oh anything that's
the best one oh this thing I read over
the past few days while preparing for
this interview was that you scored the
fastest goal ever in Peruvian so it
would be the one off so you remember
where that was no Mickey mexico in
mexico in the US I didn't know oh you
know how are ya that's gonna be very
bong the restaurant let's do it yeah
a limb or they lost let's talk about the
fans is there any difference between the
Latin American the German and the
Premier League fans lee daniel no but
there was no what did I jcpenney si si
si si yes I think there's one small
difference we Latinos are hot-blooded
and in crowds were quick to get excited
you notice that mainly in Latin America
the crowds are almost always more
restless and there are more fights
problema tuvimos una con we had a
scandal with buca Riva in copa
libertadores it was horrible Jim coming
Tanya I heard about pepper spray company
and I was here that was not pleasant
yeah but some vocalize how they think
Germans are a bit quieter and more
respectful I don't of course there's
always someone that doesn't apply to but
just a few lyssa this I've thought but
it was when we booked 10 so do you know
if you watch this I read that you didn't
get along with the Chelsea fans did I
bring me on his back true not at all I
never had any problems it's also been
said that your performance in England
wasn't the best during that time morning
I get a because it won't just let me up
each other woman I've also heard
comments along those lines look that's
just not true i came to chelsea because
of marino and three months later he left
and then I didn't play for them anymore
at least not the way I'd been hoping for
a yoy Steve I was loaned out to Bremen
and then I switched to another team
because I wanted to play it all day LOL
does it hurt to be criticized in your
own country one thought winacott diggity
dig in endo put up your vice oh yeah
anything else it's hard I put a deal
thank you I was confused because I
ordered a pisco sour and they brought me
a water that's why I laughed exactly
viewers will be wondering why we're
laughing we'll have a pisco sour after
the interview dynamic with an underage
boy under a telephone before sorry um
Vicki Thomas what were we talking about
oh yes very little wildomar it's a
complicated subject thanks to the press
a lot of people think that I just go on
holiday to Peru and don't dedicate any
of my time to the country we actually I
have no idea what it's all about
liliana's exactamente what is dima would
you feel a bit up anytime you wanna the
subject comes up a lot in the press
everything whenever I'm in Peru don't
worry don't people try to get each other
to say all kinds of things but if I go
to a restaurant or if I'm just out and
about all that happens is that people
ask for a photo so it's a strange topic
but i think it has a lot to do with the
press see that's why I say it's a
strange subject but I imagine it comes
from the press do you think it when
people say you're performing better in
Europe than you did for Peru as an
Argentine I often have to hear that
about the Argentinian players well yes
performance is a broad term Peru haven't
qualified for the world cup for years
and as a national team we haven't
achieved anything for a long time no
como seelix you know cozy yeah the
person representing this group of
players is me obviously so the whole
subject revolves around me it's always
about his performance but it's not about
his performance that's the whole team
who haven't reached their goal but then
again I am the captain hook up you done
I mean he does everything you're the
captain
cheers Cheers hello hello what hit them
we still haven't played with Peru in the
world cup would it still be possible
this is he conocido isilo erotic rollio
it's move officially go in all people
probably not that's what I wanted most
in my career I would have loved it but
it didn't happen and it probably won't
now let me tell him into Naboo you know
that's how football is and life in
general I think that there are things
you don't even get when you push really
hard for could you see yourself coaching
Peru no no me no I've always said I
couldn't I don't want to be a coach the
job takes a lot of your time and you're
off and away from your family yo it
takes over your life mucho tiempo star
liquid familia mutat employee they study
yeah now I've been doing this for so
long I prefer to spend time with my
family we done stole any choice oh lo
que quiero estar a futon boom oh that's
why I say no you know but I never rule
it out altogether yeah it's me it's
always possible in the distant future
he's a square pass out it's Biddle you
know maybe it could happen I hope not
because it's not what I want do you get
on with the Argentine coaches for
charging ten coaches if I have well be
the one you have now coach is the
Peruvian national team everything here
would he know anything okay no was it
seemed we die I only just met him I'm
training with him soon for the copa
america but he comes across as really
nice we went to a restaurant chat a bit
about his ideas I was very motivated and
enthusiastic I hope he's successful Maui
epidemic leave every cloud oh you're a
cake how will you spend your afternoon
now you've had training and lunch i get
a family time of the point oh yeah i'll
go see the kids do you have siestas if i
have time but the kids are just getting
out he's cool we train hard as you but i
doubt i'll get a siesta me de la manana
hey see do you speak spanish at home yes
english and english no all I Spanish at
home why not do you go on holiday to
Peru to see family my holidays are
shorter this year though because of the
copa america but what I'm in Peru I try
to visit them what do you miss about
peru in your hair family i miss the food
a lot and my parents of course and the
rest of my family I me yeah canadia
Pizarro thank you very much you're
welcome